foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
so you want to kill him
you want to kill him
I want to kill him
I'm going to kill you oh for better of
course yeah
but it looks like we have ourselves a
genuine conundrum
if you will a real life dilemma sure
I thought we'd play a game
one hand
within a desires who lives
and who does not
you come here thinking there is a way
out of this world for you Mr Wick
or is not
the song
sacrificure
weapons
if you win
the table will honor its word
we will have your freedom
but you want tickets
blades
pistols
[Music]
dueling pistols
30 paces
in the event that both parties survive
each will approach the other at
increments of 10 Paces until only one
remains
[Music]
all right
bonjour Mr weak and welcome
to low resistance a little far from home
aren't you well your little Act of
uncivil Disobedience inspired me John
I'm branching out
spreading my wings
how goes the ground farewell to him
coming to an end
so it seems so it seems
42 regular wasn't it
Kevlar front to back the latest and
Ballistic Chic appropriate for all
formal occasions weddings funerals high
table duels
after all man has to look his best when
it's time to get married
or buried